we've been wondering whether Barack
Obama will endorse one of the Democratic
primary candidates for 2020
maybe his former Vice President Joe
Biden before the primary is over and
it's not clear that Barack Obama is
going to get involved in this primary
but we now have heard from Trump's
former adviser Valerie Jarrett who says
that number one Barack Obama is quote
very concerned about what is going on in
the United States read Trump and that he
will be getting involved in the 2020
campaign in some form with the goal of
ultimately defeating the president
Donald Trump let's assume she's right
okay
so we're saying this is what Valerie
Jarrett has said President Obama thinks
and will do and I can't imagine she
would speak without knowing that for a
fact so let's imagine that it's true for
the purposes of our discussion today it
appears as though Barack Obama does not
plan on getting involved in the primary
and my thought is that this is the right
decision and I'm gonna tell you why
I'm guessing Barack Obama understands
and everybody around Barack Obama
understands realizes that there's very
little upside long-term for Democrats of
Barack Obama getting involved in the
primary now this is not why didn't
Elizabeth Warren endorsed Bernie during
the primary if she liked him so much
Obama's relationship to the presidency
and candidates is very different than
that of Elizabeth Warren's number one
Barack Obama was President of the United
States number two
one of the current Democratic primary
candidates is Barack Obama's former vice
president so I see this as a no win for
Barack Obama to get involved in the
primary if Obama comes out and endorses
Joe Biden it furthers the DNC
establishment narrative it opens up the
door to more claims of an unbalanced
primary in which the DNC or quote
establishment Democrats are meddling and
whether it's true or not a former
president saying that he wants his
former VP to be the nominee the election
right after the DNC screwed Bernie in
favor of Hillary it doesn't look good
so whatever gain might be calculated for
Barack Obama to come out now and endorse
Joe Biden I think has far more negatives
outweigh it
if Obama not endorses Biden during the
primary and Biden does not get the
nomination then there's the question of
whether Barack Obama has weakened the
power of his endorsement by initially
endorsing somebody who doesn't win and
then having to go out and campaign for
somebody that he didn't endorse during
the primary if instead of Joe Biden
Barack Obama prefers somebody else
imagine that Barack Obama prefers Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or whoever
and he endorses them during the primary
and Biden ends up winning who is of
course leading in the polls right now
it's the same problem in Reverse how
strong is Obama support of Biden as the
nominee if Obama supported Sanders
during the primary and I understand that
many politicians endorse one person
during the primary that person loses
then they support somebody else it is
different when you are a former
president and it is different when one
of the candidates is your former vice
president so to me this is fine okay
support who you like in the primary and
then you vote to defeat Trump no matter
who the nominee is from the people that
are running but the perception of it not
going right for Barack Obama wouldn't be
good President Obama imagined that he
has built up a sort of specific amount
of political capital it's a lot okay the
former president who has seen very
favorably by Americans has a lot of
political capital but it's not unlimited
political capital and I don't believe
that there is a long-term gain for
Barack Obama to get involved in the
primary in the context of working to
defeat Donald Trump which is the goal
what Obama should do during the primary
it's two things number one demand and
lobby for an open transparent primary to
the extent that he's willing to do that
and it may not be a significant extent
and I understand that
and number two Barack Obama during the
primary should be working to push back
against all of the voter suppression
efforts from Republicans to ensure that
when the time comes to vote in November
of 2020 every vote is counted everyone
who wants to vote gets to vote and have
their votes counted which will help the
eventual Democratic nominee when the
time comes for the DNC to formally
nominate the winner of the primary
at the convention Barack Obama should be
there introducing them and speaking at
the DNC and rallying the troops but
there is not an advantage to him getting
involved at this point in the primary
endorsing somebody now there are some
really low-energy beta comments from
Republicans saying that it's unbecoming
of a president a former president to get
involved at all in the presidential race
and that it looks bad give me a break
okay you're pathetic it's unbecoming to
have a president like Trump embarrassing
the country day in and day out on the
national stage Barack Obama is concerned
about the future of this country and he
wants to work to change that trajectory
or at least according to Valerie Jarrett
he's planning on working to change that
and he should be applauded for it but I
completely understand why Barack Obama
is not not likely to get involved in
this primary and I actually agree with
that decision
for the strategic reasons that I've
outlined if you disagree with my
conclusion or if you simply disagree
with how I've built up that conclusion I
want to hear from you I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single
class offered by Skillshare after those
two months if you want to keep your
subscription Skillshare super affordable
at less than ten bucks a month get
better at whatever it is that you're
passionate about or discover something
brand-new that you didn't even know that
you would love and join skill shares
other 7 million users by clicking the
link underneath this video
[Music]